hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about what causes
cracked heels okay now it's a vitamin b3
deficiency that's what it is and another
name for vitamin b3 deficiency is called
pellagra now there are levels of this
pellagra from very minor subclinical to
very advanced and you know you just
don't wake up one day with pellagra you
start with little tiny symptoms and
believe it or not one of the first
symptoms of pellagra it has to do with
your your gastrointestinal tracts
diarrhea and a lot of upset inflammation
in your gut and then it leads to the
skin so there's a lot of skin problems
with vitamin b3 deficiencies which is
niacin okay so here are the symptoms of
ìiî deficiency sensitivity to light
cracked skin rough skin cracked roughed
cracked skin especially on your heels
odor sensitivity you have sensitivity to
odors like you could really smell things
and it irritates you more than it should
dizziness with sudden movements so
everything is like hyper sensitive
desire to quarrel fight with someone
black tongue now there's a lot of other
symptoms but these are some of the
common ones
now the foods that you should be eating
to to make sure you have b3 would be you
know some of the animal meats turkey
chicken pork mushroom fish grass-fed
beef seeds avocado now it could be the
diet but normally it's not the diet so
what we want to do is you want to look
deeper and the number one cause of
vitamin b3 deficiency in fact all of the
vitamins would be your gastrointestinal
tract is damaged you might have
inflammation you might have a gastric
bypass surgery where they took out your
intestines it could be from Crohn's or
celiac or irritable bowel syndrome but
something happened in your gut that
destroyed the lining of your digestive
tract and now you can't absorb that so
you're going to have to consume a little
bit more B vitamins than you normally do
just so it can be absorbed so that's
something we want to look at if it is
your GI tract then what you want to do
is you want to take al
glutamine you want to take lactic acid
from kombucha tea you want to have more
of the fermented foods and bone broth is
a really good source of l-glutamine as
well now if your alcoholic this could
also be the reason why you're deficient
in the B vitamins if you have history a
lot of antibiotics that can destroy the
ability to absorb b3 and last one is too
much corn now what's the connection
between corn and b3 there's a research
that shows that certain countries that
pretty much are really really poor in
their living off just primarily corn
become very deficient in b3 and they get
pellagra and so I'll put a link down
there to get more data on that but corn
does not have help tryptophan this amino
acid l-tryptophan turns into b3 so if
you don't have it that's why you're
going to be deficient so consuming the
diet of you know corn you're going to
have a problem with this deficiency
right here so we just wanted to do a
video on the causes of cracked heels as
compared to just putting a lotion on
your feet and bean that's going to fix
it this is more of an internal problem
find the cause go ahead and correct it
and thanks for watching